الامنيه استعدادا لمثول الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب خلال ايام امام هذه المحكمه
لمواجهه لائحه اتهام ومحاكمه يراها ترامب
اضطهادا سياسيا وتدخلًا في الانتخابات
وتوظيفا للقضاء من قبل الحزب الديمقراطي
من السابق لاوانه القول ان الديمقراطيين
قاموا بالفعل بتسييس النظام القضائي خاصه
ان المحكمه لم تقل كلمه ابعد فالسيد ترامب
نفسه كان عين ثلاثه من قضاه المحكمه
العليا ولذلك يمكن القول انه قد ملا
المحكمه بالقضاه المناهضين للاجهاض ما ادى
الى نقض حكم بشان الاجهاض وعليه تسيس
القضاء لصالح الجمهوريين
عاصفه الانتقادات والاتهامات من المعسكر
الجمهوري في مجملها تضفي طابعا سياسيا على
القضيه وبدا لافتا خلالها ان الجمهوريين
في مجلس النواب اعلى صوتا من نظرائهم في
مجلس الشيوخ وان منافسي ترامب المحتملين
في الانتخابات المقبله اصطفوا معه ولكن
على نحو لا يقوض دعواهم بان ترامب لم يعد
ملائما للرئاسه او اهلا لقياده
الحزبها حريه
لا اعتقد ان هذه الاتهامات ستضر به لاننا
لسنا ديمقراطيه فعاله فالحزب الجمهوري
اختزل في شخص واحد ويمكن رؤيه ذلك من خلال
ردود الفعل على لائحه الاتهام بما في ذلك
بعض قاده الحزب الذين كانوا ينتقدون ترامب
في الماضي ووصفوا هذه المحاكمه الان
بالسياسيه
امتناع الرئيس بايدن عن التعليق بشان
القضيه قابله احتفاء من فريق واسع من
الديمقراطيين يرى في توجيه تهم جنائيه الى
ترامب اخيرا انتصارا للقانون فيما لم يخفي
فريق اخر امتعاضه لان التهم جاءت في قضيه
يعدونها الاقل اهميه ما قد يؤثر سلبا في
قضايا اخرى يرونها اكثر خطوره وعلى راسها
الهجوم على الكونجرس والوثائق السريه
وانتخابات ولايه جورجيا الولايات المتحده
امام اختبار جديد بعد توجيه تهم جنائيه
الى رئيس سابق في خطوه غير مسبوقه والجدل
المتصاعد بهذا الشان لا يعمق حاله
الانقسام السياسي فحسب بل قد يزعزع ثقه
الامريكيين او فريق منهم بنزاهه النظامين
القضائي والانتخابي
مرض هاشم الجزيره نيويورك